well first of all Britain isn't going to
donate any fighter jets to Ukraine at
this time uh typhoon is we've been
consistent in saying we're not going to
deliver typhoon tranche one uh is not a
plane that would be suitable but also we
make the Clear Point that um you know
this is not about gifting weapon systems
this is a good thing a platform and with
that if anyone follows Formula One you
don't just gift a car you have to gift a
a pit a pit team of hundreds of people
and none of us standing here no European
nation is going to put Europe British
forces or or British Air Force personnel
into Ukraine in the middle of that war
zone we've always been clear on that
what we are talking about and it links
to the earlier question is resilience of
Ukraine how can Ukraine stand firm after
this how they can deter and they will
need more fighter capability so starting
the basics of helping train cohorts of
ukrainians for the long term to fly
aircraft whichever aircraft they choose
to buy or develop is what it's important
now to discuss and you know Ukraine have
expressed I think a preference for f-16s
we don't hold those in our inventory but
fundamentally I think it's about
training and enabling that will take
some time considerable time I don't
think this is the magic one that we'll
solve today what we'll solve today is
giving Ukraine the same effects an
aircraft can deliver an aircraft can
deliver anti-air ground support and deep
strike the Storm Shadow gifting we gave
recently will it help achieve that deep
strike and build on the 80 kilometer
range of the high mile system and the
m270s the anti-air well we've all seen
how much donations Germany and others
have given on anti-air missiles from
surface to air Ukraine is actually very
well covered by that anti-earn as we've
seen the Russian Air Force doesn't
really take off and has to rely on
firing missiles over the Caspian Sea to
hit keys so you know we can deliver the
effect without necessarily rushing in
aircraft that we either don't have or
aren't suitable for this war and then
when we can talk about after the war we
talk about the resilience then it's
important that we're busy training their
pilots and their capabilities